Lebanon's new prime minister Hassan yep
has finalized his cabinet lineup it took
weeks of political horse-trading
even though those who were fighting over
seats are allies and part of the ruling
Alliance the ABS critics call him a pawn
of the political elite but addressing
the nation he tried to defend his
cabinet at a time of mass protests over
Lebanon's worst economic crisis in
decades
Carmelita Giamatti Muttalib ahem we will
endeavor to answer their demands to
ensure that we have an independent
judiciary to bring back stolen money to
fight corruption to protect the poorest
social classes from high taxation the
tackle unemployment and to put in place
a new electoral law that brings everyone
together under one national identity
that the street has asked for news of
the government announcement brought
protestors who have been demanding a new
leadership back onto the streets they
gathered in central Beirut the epicenter
of a three months old movement to topple
the political class they accused of
mismanagement and corruption protesters
disputed Deb's insistence that the
twenty ministers were specialists with
no political loyalties I'm here because
I don't trust this new government that's
gonna be formed because it came from the
people who have been in charge for the
past 30 years and in bad doesn't bring
good and bad only brings bad
yes government is also being criticized
for being controlled by the Iranian
backed Hezbollah and for being one-sided
political opponents of the ruling
Alliance including outgoing Prime
Minister saddle Haredi refused to join
the government they're just playing the
same book that they played 100 days ago
so as if as if they're just stopping us
in the face they're laughing at us
they're like who are those people what
are they doing on the streets the
government faces many challenges in the
midst of an unprecedented nationwide
multi-sectarian uprising Deb's
government is expected to receive the
vote of confidence in Parliament but it
is the support of international
investors and donors that Lebanon needs
to get out of the economic and financial
crisis the last time the UN created
international support group for Lebanon
met in December it made no financial
pledges and instead called for a
credible government that listens to
public opinion expressed in the ongoing
popular uprising for weeks many Lebanese
have been struggling to make their
voices heard
yes in Yaseen told the security forces
protecting parliament building that the
steel and concrete barriers won't be
able to protect those in power I'm here
to demonstrate against the corrupt
regime in Lebanon that has been raping
this country for 30 years or more they
were the Warlord's that had to compile
that killed each other that broken us
into sects broken us into groups to kill
each other
there is determination to continue their
struggle or what people here call their
revolution but the government
announcement on Tuesday sent a clear
message that the established parties are
still in power
Lebanon's crisis is not over XANA
further al Jazeera Beirut dr. macro is a
policy analyst at the Arab Center at
Washington DC he says the ruling
political class is still running things
behind the scenes most of the government
is not independent at the status quo
government we can still see the vodka
class behind the scene basically running
the show we don't see independent faces
we don't see especially in key economic
and financial portfolio don't see names
that give the passion of the form so the
problem is the Parliament is the product
of this volume of this Parliament is in
the hand of the ruling class no there's
no way out of it maybe if we don't do it
no the election this week in Lebanon the
protester they clear the the week of
anger because it's been more than 90
days and there was really no urgency
from the from the politicians leaving
the country at this point so we don't
see any u-unless because the system will
be the positive shop for a shock of the
poem extensive obviously we don't see it
there after now we have to see the
transition now we will have a new
especially interior minister he comes
for the repeat background we will see
how they will did with the protesters we
will continue the same trend of the past
week which is more confrontational
protesters where we see more trying to
appease offer some real plan effect to
artesia but at this point I can be the
first impression is bad and it's Eastern
being that starts somehow between the
two but the crucial I think we have to
see how much security measures will be
taken